another Democrat divide congresswoman
Alexandria ocasio-cortez calling out
President Biden for not including
illegal immigrants in his blanket pardon
for people federally convicted of simple
marijuana possession she also had this
message for her party
the Democratic party has not tried in in
terms of Latino electorates and I mean
where's our Dream Act where is our
immigration reform
and even recently with President Biden's
marijuana executive order I very much
applaud that he went there but
um he Exempted people who were convicted
when if they were convicted while they
were undocumented joining us live is
former acting DHS secretary Chad wolf
Chad good morning to you what do you
think about that comment from AOC
well I think it just shows her
priorities and perhaps the priority to
the left look their idea of solving this
crisis and solving the immigration
crisis and really trying to appeal to
certain voters is to give them blanket
amnesty
or in this case obviously uh dealing
with pardons for those here in the
country illegally so I think it's wrong
it's an America last strategy and I
think the American people want to see uh
policies uh from either party that's
really impacting Americans every single
day and this isn't it on the marijuana
part of this I mean you've heard a lot
of legal Scholars say really nobody is
convicted of a federal marijuana
possession crime that seems to be
something that's left to the states and
localities but bigger picture Chad after
his Lawless approach to immigration and
the Border in total why is he pretending
to play tough guy with illegals when it
comes to marijuana
well I think that's right again I think
this is the uh the left's kind of appeal
they believe their appeal to Latino
voters and I think what we have seen is
that most Latinos that we have talked to
that I have talked to want a secure
border they want folks to come into the
country illegally they don't want to see
those that came here illegally rewarded
with pardons or any other type of uh
behavior from the the federal government
so I think again it's the wrong approach
I think it's a misreading of that
Community they want Law and Order they
want to process at that border and you
know AOC and others need to be focusing
on solving the crisis on that border we
have a historic crisis on that border
that that party is not talking about and
it's a shame because they're in power
they have the ability to solve this
today if they choose to Chad migrants
including Venezuelans who've been sent
back to Mexico are now building a tent
city on the other side of the Border
because they're hoping that this new
Biden Administration policy that sends
Venezuelans back to Mexico which is
essentially the remain in Mexico policy
is going to eventually get overturned by
the administration what do you make of
the Biden Administration doing this
right now some people have said that
this is a positive step in the right
direction others say that man oh man
this is just a drop in the bucket
well I would agree I think this is too
little too late
um I think what they're seeing is that
an enforcement measure such as the one
that they're taking against the
Venezuelans perhaps could work uh but
it's just a small like you said drop in
the bucket the Venezuelan is just one
population set that's coming across that
border in historic numbers and so if
they want to get serious about it they
need to not only look at Venezuelans but
Cubans and all the other nationalities
130 nationalities are coming across that
border so I think the numbers that
you're going to continue to see over
month after month after month even after
this policy has been instituted you're
going to continue to see these
astronomically High numbers and it's not
going to have a material effect of
what's going on at that border it's just
going to affect one small population
such as the Venezuelans but you're going
to see other populations and other
numbers coming across that border in
historic numbers that we will continue
to see unfortunately Chad Wolfe has a
new op-ed out on foxnews.com entitled it
is entitled Americans deserve Solutions
not excuses of course it is on the
border crisis Chad thank you so much for
joining us best of luck with the op-ed
and have a great weekend
all right thank you guys I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis